aux abords du parlement dans une tempête
de klaxon assourdissantes des députés en
caisse le journée
[Musique]
autour l'ancien militaire ministre sous
le gouvernement de stephen harper n'a
pas réussi à convaincre les
conservateurs qu'il était l'homme de la
situation
son règne à la tête du parti n'aura même
pas duré un an et demi je vais
humblement quitter mon poste le chef
déchu a évité les médias et s'est
adressé aux canadiens sur twitter
c'était une fierté pour moi de diriger
le parti nombreux détracteurs lui
reprochent d'avoir été incapable
d'exprimer clairement ses positions
après avoir fait volte face sur la taxe
carbone et des armes à feu et oui nous
tous là une fois de plus changé son
fusil d'épaulé la semaine dernière sur
le convoi de camionnettes
du mal à nous suivre dit ce député
albertain c'est pour ça que j'ai voté
pour qu'il soit démis de ses fonctions
de chef on ne peut pas plaire à tout le
monde et c'est là où monsieur autour a
manqué d'audace de dire voici ce que je
crois et voici où je vais amener le
parti mais il existe aussi un problème
plus profond sein de la famille
conservatrice on peut pas nier qu
effectivement il y avait des divisions
qui avaient des frictions dans le parti
puis avec dijon
[Musique]
plusieurs députés de l'ouest n'ont pas
apprécié le recentrage des runes o'toole
voulait opérer au sein du parti surtout
après s'être présenté comme un vrai
bleus pendant la course au leadership
déjà été satisfait du message des
changements je dirais de cap qui avait
été enclenchée après la course à la
chefferie aujourd'hui des élus notamment
du québec s'inquiètent de voir la
formation politique prendre un virage un
peu trop adroits moi je suis
conservateur je resterai au parti
conservateur du canada tant et aussi
longtemps que chopard cela sera parce
qu'on sort va pas fonctionner faut unir
les deux shows du net une tâche qui
s'annonce difficile la loi 21 par
exemple bien des députés des prairies
veulent que le parti la dénonce haut et
fort ce qui pourrait miner les chances
des conservateurs au québec croit cet
ancien ministre de stephen harper n'a
pas
vendu
avec une unité qui était propre au
québec qui a fonctionné alors faudrait
pas que ces efforts
mais après une journée éprouvante
certains pensent déjà à l'avenir c'est
une occasion pour
pour recommencer notre parti comment
regagner la confiance des électeurs et
reprendre le pouvoir et une au tour
offre cette leçon
a dit m les canadiens et ils ont besoin
de parti conservateur à la fois
inspirant et rassembleur et si leur ans
partait radio canada
[Applaudissements]